was geht hier ist ein max und herzlich
willkommen zum heutigen video wir machen
heute etwas komplett anderes und zwar
einen girlfriend hat ja hier lernt heute
meine einzig wahre freundin kennen der
ihr habt ihr bestimmt schon das ein oder
andere mal irgendwo irgend welchen
bildern gesehen oder so und ja heute
machen wir ein video zusammenbringen
hast du kannst noch haare ein mann kommt
dass das warten hat ein ende
hier ist sie meine wunderschöne freundin
die ist noch ein bisschen schlecht dass
du wirst du wirst oder hätte besteht ihr
schicken
wir machen heute folgende sich vor der
kammer wir machen heute freuen wir uns
sagte wir machen einen antrag stellen
uns gegenseitig fragen die wir besser
über den anderen zu beantworten
nicht immer aber das ist jetzt eine ganz
besondere nehmen wird nimmt es und
gewann mit der allerersten frage ich
stelle ich als erstes und zwar welcher
song hat damals bei unserem allerersten
welcher sommer da ist unserem
allerersten kuss gespielt
erlaubt ist richtig ist doch nicht
richtig denn hier komm ich bin ja nach
menton denn du wirst es gewohnt dass man
damit angeblich skala ist max factor
du bist ja manchmal manchmal war es von
dem künstler meint ständig gar nicht
mehr kennt kennt ihr das mit den frauen
habe ich ja keine macht arbeit
überzeugen
warum machen wir sagt kiefer eine
granate 10 von 10
sobald ich die gar nicht aber das mache
ich welches sternzeichen habe ich immer
richtig manchmal
also bis zu sein manchmal hat man hier
eine stimme
genau gleich mal hörst du diese sexy
beißen mit mit stiefel die sofas und das
knie gehen musste
sie sehen eine richtig geile sache habt
ihr auch schon mal nach sechs jahren
magst du es lieber wenn ich deine zipse
kreide oder reize selbst drehen was
haben sie in diesem tag zu lange
fest ich danke schön ist was wir sehen
diesen schritt fettmasse so nächste
frage was redet überhaupt verstehe ich
so meine letzte frage jetzt welche
fußballer ja richtig sagst du gut
gemacht
jetzt hast du glaub ich 22 punkte erst
jetzt 22 punkte und ich habe ich habe
hier fünf punkte bis 22 mal sehen ob du
noch gewinnen kannst ich kenne ich ja
nicht 69
ok stehe daher zur frage
mit dem entscheid teilnehmen und hat mit
ihrer mutter genannt hat und warum das
macht ja schön wenn du das bringt mich
nicht um mich nicht gehört dass die
gesagt die spieler und jeden tag hinein
rache zu gast ist dann kann ich glaube
du hast die so gemacht wegen schiri in
daytona beach gültigkeit ist reiner
vorbei
ich finde du siehst ein bisschen aus wie
boris becker
die bos besser wenn er schöne frau ist
der islam
er hat eine gute woche
so leute das war's noch von meinem
heutigen video ich hoffe es geht sicher
dass früher alles klar es geht was das
gemacht was liegt da dass man das los
wie man freundin lucia sagt wir haben
gern tag gedreht
auch du auch mit martin grab auf einem
kanal ich war schon ein gibt es den link
gibt es ja ich mag ihn an dem schreiben
macht man machen